la maison grand court
dans les années
110 julien gonnot montbrun un des plus
riches colons de bourbon fait construire
deux grandes maisons en pierres du
numérique a et la seconde au
centre-ville de saint-paul cette
résidence urbaine ne donne sur deux rues
côté chaussée royale l'entrée officielle
au centre de la parcelle la maison et à
l'arrière un bâtiment u abritant
logement des domestiques cuisine et
dépendances
la maison est construite sur une
terrasse afin d'éviter les inondations
lors de la montée des eaux de l'étang
avec leurs warrants que ceux tenus par
de lourdes colonnes les façades est et
ouest sont alors d'un luxe sans
précédent dans l'île
réalisé par des tailleurs de pierre et
des mâts sont venus d'inde la maison
grandcourt mal influence néoclassique et
franco pondu syrienne
la distribution intérieure est elle
aussi d'une grande symétrie au rez de
chaussée comme l étage toutes les pièces
en ganis autour d'une salle centrale
inoccupé dès la fin du 19e siècle la
maison se détériore peu à peu
totalement en ruine à la fin des années
1940 elle doit sa renaissance à
l'installation d'une école
franco-chinoise en 1958
protégé au titre des monuments
historiques depuis 1984 la maison grand
court vient d'être racheté par la ville
de saint paul qui prévoit un important
programme de réhabilitation